[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité Emmanuel Macron le
président de la République l'a annoncé
239 nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
vont être créées TBO la chaîne du groupe
le telégram s'est rendu dans l'un des
centres de formation de la gendarmerie
dans le finisterère dans l'actualité
également la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires qui va augmenter
dans certaines communes on vous explique
dans un instant ce qui va se passer par
exemple en Savoie et en Haute Savoie
avec les équipes de Montblanc il se peut
que vous ne soyez pas partis en vacances
cet été sur reportager pour vous vous
verrez dans ce journal qu'il est encore
temps nous partirons pour la Martinique
où la saison des croisières est sur le
point de débuter nous partirons rêver au
grand large avec avec ATV Martinique et
puis dans ce journal des images
exceptionnelles de l'exposition Van Gog
qui se tient à auovert sur wise visite
guidé des derniers voyages du maître
hollandais à la fin de ce
journal voilà nous commençons ce journal
avec cette série de plusieurs attentat
et tentativ d'attentat commis tout au
long de la soirée et de la nuit du
dimanche 8 octobre sur l'ensemble de la
Corse parmi ces actions certaines ont
été signées par le FLNC dans un
communiqué dénonçant le processus
politique en de tracer les contours
d'une autonomie à la Corse heureusement
ces événements n'ont fait aucun blessé
ce sont des images de télé paisé
Emmanuel Macron l'avait annoncé la
semaine dernière 239 nouvelles brigades
fixes et mobiles seront créées en France
d'ici 2027 et pour compléter ces
brigades 2144 gendarmes supplémentaires
devront être formés à l'école de
gendarmerie de châolin dans le Finistère
les instructeurs se préparent donc à
accueillir un plus grand nombre d'élèves
cette année
regardez ce reportage d'oraa le nôtre
pour TBO sur
[Musique]
place la matinée commence par un
entraînement au tir au moment de tirer
coucher dans votre position donc là il
faut arriver à bien vous relâcher à
l'école de gendarmerie de châolin ses
élèves aspirent à devenir gendarmes mais
avant d'aller sur le terrain ils doivent
d'abord suivre une formation de 9 mois
on table sur un savoir-être et un
savoirfaire le savoir-être un
comportement digne pour être gendarme
donc militaire discipliné respectueux
euh également des bases de de militarité
et également un savoir-faire puisque
demain ils seront sur le terrain ils
devront acquérir des quand même des des
bases des clés pour pouvoir travailler
239 nouvelles brigades vont être créées
en France d'ici 2027 une annonce du
président qui n'est pas sans impact sur
les écoles de gendarmerie pour former de
nouveaux gendarmes les écoles augmentent
leurs effectifs ici à châolin le nombre
d'élèves va passer de 800 à 1000 en
janvier alors sur les infrastructures
vont être saturer hein puisque quasiment
on a le maximum de capacité de l'école
qui va être atteinte on a des crédits
pour améliorer et agrandir les salles de
cours parce que évidemment la capacité
d'accueil en nombre de lit c'est une
chose la capacité d'accueil dans les
salles de de formation c une autre mais
on a un budget prévu pour ça
pour agrandir nos sales cours et
augmenter nos capacités d'accueil dans
la formation en Bretagne 12 brigades
vont être recéées trois dans le
Finistère et les Côtes d'Armor deux dans
le morbillan et quatre en î
Villaines tout à fait autre chose en
Savoie et en Haute Savoie près de 350
communes peuvent désormais surtaxer les
propriétaires de résiden secondaires
avec pour objectif d'apporter aux plus
petites des communes une recette fiscale
complémentaire afin de renforcer le
logement permanent et d'aider les gens à
rester au pays regardez ce reportage de
notre partenaire 8 Montblanc sur
place propriétaire de résidence
secondaire prenez garde la facture
devrait être plus salée d'ici à 1 an
jusqu'alors seules les villes de 50000
habitants dans lequel ce logé étit
compliqué avait la possibilité de voter
cette surtaxation depuis août 2023
2263 autres communes se sont ajoutés au
niveau national des municipalités qui
avaient jusqu'au 1er octobre pour voter
ce nouvel outil fiscale à Cluse les élus
ont décidé à la quasi unanimité de
majorer cette fameuse taxe d'habitation
sur les résidences secondaires alors en
terme de chiffre effectivement ça va
être impacté sur une à peu près 500
logements euh pour un montant total
puisque la la la taxe est Moné qu' 30 %
de environ 63000 €. mais cette taxe là
nous permet surtout de rendre incitatif
la la réhabilitation des logements voire
pour les loués comme pour les logements
vacants effectivement puisque l'objectif
de tout ça c'est de de pouvoir
accueillir des habitants sans forcément
construire de des logements et des
bâtiments neufs les régions montagneuses
et balnéires sont les principales zones
concernées par cette problématique de l
frroid un phénomène qui impacte le
nombre de logements disponibles sur le
marché mais plus généralement toute
l'économie locale songez bien qu'une
commune comme laclusa une commune comme
meugev perd des habitants de manière
significative donc on avait besoin
d'avoir ce travail là c'est justement ce
qu'on cherche à faire non pas à freiner
les résidence secondaire bien sûr chacun
est libre d'avoir une résidence
secondaire mais bien se rendre compte
que des résidences secondairirees dans
des villages mort où il n'y a plus
d'habitant ça n'a plus aucun sens donc
chasser la population locale euh qui va
aller habiter ailleurs parce qu'elle n'a
plus les moyens de se loger c'est
criminel hein disons-le pour le pour la
vie économique de d'un territoire et
donc il faut envoyer un signal clair que
quand on est résident secondaire on doit
prendre une charge plus importante des
dépenses locales par rapport à ceux qui
vivent dans le territoire cette
augmentation de la taxe d'habitation des
résidences secondaires pouvait s'étendre
de 5 à 60 %. une mesure attendue de
longues dates par les élus locaux à
l'image de chamoni avec plus de 2 tiers
des logements qui sont des résidences
secondaires représentant un total de
10000 logements la mairie a voté une
majoration de la THRs de 50
%. il n'y a pas qu'à Paris que la
psychose de la punesse de lit ferage à
Montpellier la société de transport en
commun a dû faire appel à des renforts
au poil en l'occurrence trois chiens
renifleurs de race working coquer qui au
final n'ont rien trouvé regardez ce
reportage de Tiffanie h pour via
occitan
la star de l'opération détection c'est
lui Tito working coquer de 3 ans à
l'aide de sa truffe il passe au peigne
fin les véhicule à la recherche de la
petite bête qui provoque des
démangeaisons rien que d'en parler la
punae de lit les chiens qui font les
punaes de lit ne font que les punaises
de lit voilà sinon c'est trop aléatoire
pour les chiens quoi un être humain
c'est 20000 molécules qu'on arrive à
mémoriser un chien c'est 1 million donc
voilà le chien doit détecter uniquement
les punaes de lit et les vivant alors au
début c'est la pugnacité du chien c'est
des chiens de chasse donc on leura
apprend à chercher une balle en fin de
compte au départ qu'ils aient l'amour de
leur balle et en fin de compte on réduit
la grosseur de la balle au fur à mesure
jusqu'à tempant que ce soit une petite
et tête d'épingle et en fin de compte
après on rajoute l'odeur qu'on veut lui
injecter c'està-dire la punaise de lit
les explosifs les stupéfiants et une
fois qu'il a il a le nez dessus et qu'il
bouge plus on lui jette sa balle c'est
sa récompense après un premier passage
pas de marquage c'est positif cela
signifie qu'il n'y a pas de punase de
lit dans le véhicule inspecé ce jour-là
ni lui ni Roxane passé avant lui dans
d'autres bus non'ont flirer l'insecte
qui s'invite un peu partout bien malgré
nous pour vérifier qu'il n'a pas la
truffe altérée une deuxième phase de
test est réalisée avec des échantillons
de Puna vivante trouvé à tous les coups
test validé tout le monde est rassuré
c'est la première fois qu'on fait une
opération comme celle-ci voilà avec tout
ce que nous avons entendu dans les
médias et tout ce qui circule sur les
réseaux sociaux l'objectif c'était de
nous rassurer de rassurer aussi voilà
les habitants de la métropole et tous
ceux qui utilisent les les véhicules de
notre de notre réseau et puis nos
salariés pour rassurer encore plus ses
usagers la TH précise également que ces
différents bus et rames de tramois sont
nettoyés quotidiennement à ce jour selon
la société de transport aucune punaise
de lit n'a jamais été
détectée installé à 3 le maroquiniier
maison Jean Rousseau a recruté 24
stagiaires afin de leur apprendre les
gestes nécessaires à la fabrication
d'accessoires en cuir haut de gamme pour
cela ils suivent un parcours de
formation interne à l'entreprise encadré
par des formateurs et des maîtres
artisans le célèbre maroquiniier prévoit
de recruter et de former à terme 200
nouveaux collaborateurs pour son site de
saint-savine regardez ce reportage de
notre partenaire sur place Canal 32 si
les 1500 à 3000 m² de la manufacture
Jean Rousseau seront opérationnels en
janvier 2025 la formation des futurs
salariés a d'ors et déjà débuté ce lundi
au sein du parc du Grand TR les 24
premiers stagiaires entament un long
cycle de formation on sait qu'à l'issue
de 400 heures de formation généralement
on apprend uniquement les bases la
manufacture gen s'est rendu compte que
pour atteindre cette qualité on l'prend
pas à l'école donc on a travaillé
justement sur des talents parcours en
interne pour se dire artisan aujourd'hui
il faut au minima entre 2 et 5 ans Avin
de donner leur forme à des bracelets où
étui un cuir très haut de gamme ces
apprentis artisans s'exercent à
l'excellence sur du papier on retourne à
l'école alors souvent un cuteur on a
tendance à le tenir à pleineain pour
pouvoir forcer dessus alors que là on va
vouloir avoir de la précision on va
tenir le cuteur plus comme un stylo
sélectionné grâce à la méthode
recrutement par simulation ici certains
apprentis n'ont aucune expérience dans
ce domaine manufacture Jean Rousseau les
accompagne en se basant sur d'autres
qualités leur dextérité et leur
motivation j'ai presque 10 années
d'expérience dans le secrétariat médical
la chance c'est que on puisse nous
former et puis nous apprendre toutes les
compétences nécessaires pour exercer ce
métier c'est un peu un petit rêve
d'enfance avantage du bassin d'emploi
troyant un tiers des apprentis ont tout
de même une expérience plus ou moins
longue dans le secteur textile notamment
trois sont issu de l'entreprise posuse
café qui a fermé ses portes en juillet
dernier j'étais responsable des achats
fournitures donc à sa Viip toujours dans
le même au même endroit ça me change pas
beaucoup justement en terme de parcours
pour venir travailler sans attendre la
construction de la manufacture pour
monter en compétenence à partir de
janvier prochain ces apprentis soutenus
par des artisans participeront à la
production des volumes de production
assez FAI quand même qu'il puissent
échanger avec ces nouveaux artisans et à
apprendre de leur de leur expérience
également manufacture Jean Rousseau
prévoit de coordonner des séances de
recrutement chaque trimestre à terme le
site devrait employer 200
personnes et puis comme souvent dans
cetted i je vous propose de découvrir
des innovations qui visent à améliorer
notre environnement on se rend à ton
lesvoge la commune qui s'est lancé dans
la réute un qualificatif pour
réutilisation des EAU usées traité un
procédé spécifique qui permet de
débarrasser les eaux usé de leurs
bactéries pour permettre l'arrosage
d'espace vert ou de nettoyage de voiries
un reportage de la rédaction de vuge
télévision regardez voilà une eau usée
traitée qui ne devrait à l'avenir pas
repartir systématiquement dans le milieu
naturel nous sommes sur le site de la
station d'épuration de thon lesvoge qui
traite entre 1700 et 7000 m C par jour
soit 15000 équivalent habitants réparti
à Chavelot ignet et taon et c'est une
première pour une collectivité vogienne
on va expérimenter ici la réhute la
réutilisation des EAU usées traité via
ce dispositif technique qui permet de
pousser plus loin le traitement les EOS
usées traité des stations d'épuration
actuelles contiennent encore beaucoup de
de bactéries en fait on le voit pas à
l'œil nu mais elles ont encore beaucoup
d'agents pathogènes et donc donc pour
pouvoir les utiliser sur sur certains
usages il faut retirer ces dernières
bactéries qui sont encore dans l'eau
aujourd'hui on alimente le le nouvel
équipement au débit de 10 m³ heure cette
eau surtraitée en quelque sorte sera
donc à disposition de la ville de ton
qui acheminera des camions citerne à des
fins d'arrosage d'hydrocurage ou de
nettoyage des voiries pour des besoins
estimés entre 6 et 8 m C par jour dans
la première fiole donc l'eau usée telle
qu'elle sort de la station d'épuration
et donc ensuite l'eau sans les matières
sans les matières et débarrasser surtout
des bactéries puisque c'est quand même
Béri c'est l'essentiel c'est l'essentiel
il fallait se lancer parce que on s'est
rendu compte l'année dernière quand on
avait plus la possibilité de d'utiliser
l'eau pour arroser nos plantes pour
faire les hydrocurages dans nos ruces
ben on était bien embêté et qu'il
fallait se préparer à long terme à
d'autres usages le stade Saer par
exemple quand il faut l'arroser en été
c'est 50 m³ jour et là ça commence à
causer parce qu'on est encore
aujourd'hui dans du dans du pompage NAP
et là quand on sera en capacité
peut-être d'installer là-bas des
citernes d'être en capacité à ce
moment-là peut-être même d'avoir des
réseaux de transport un peu plus fluide
de cette eau bah là on aura optimisé un
point d'étape sera fait à l'issue de
l'été prochain période test avant
d'envisager l'extension de cette réhute
la réutilisation des eaux usées traitées
dans d'autres communes ou stations du
secteur stocker nos données coûte cher
en énergie et en impact environnemental
à Manille et Hau dans le sud-ouest de
Paris le ministre de la transition
numérique a inauguré un data center et
coresponsable regardez ce reportage de
notre partenaire sur place de tv78 dans
les vivelines
SZ avec une surface de plus de 10000 M
Carr ce data center s'inscrit dans la
continuité de la souveraineté européenne
télé house l'a inauguré à Manil etamo ce
lundi 2 octobre en présence du ministre
de la transition numérique et des
télécommunication nous avons là un un
centre de de données qui va être destiné
en priorité aux acteurs souverain à des
dasso système à des talè qui sont
géographiquement assez proches d'ici
puis nous avons un territoire qui est
très numérique et très fortement marqué
par la souveraineté numérique F végétal
absence de gaz frigorigène le data
center se veut écoresponsable en mettant
en place des actions concrètes pour
réduire ses émissions de gaz quand on
émet du CO2 c'est notre responsabilité
de tendre vers le réduire et c'est le
cas pour les Data Center qui consomment
beaucoup d'énergie qui consomment
beaucoup d'électricité donc notre
responsabilité c'est de ce sujet à BR
cor et mettre des actions concrètes qui
permettent d'arriver à 0 CO2 pour cette
activité que l'essence même du numérique
c'est décarboner l'économie de réduire
les flux physiques qu'il a sur terre et
de les passer sur le numérique qui
devient décarboné donc pour faire ça on
on a une obligation on ESS de remplir
cette obligation en voulant contribuer à
un avenir plus durable téh s'engage à
atteindre la neutralité carbone d'ici
2026 et puis elle s'invite de plus en
plus dans l'alimentation des Français
petit fruit rouge orangé de la famille
de la tomate c'est l'AB baie de godji
des baaies qui proviennent aujourd'hui
essentiellement du marché asiatique
pourtant dans l'Oise quelques
producteurs français se sont lancés dans
la culture de ces fruits jérô Oubron les
a goûté pour wou TV
regardz en Chine on lui prête des vertus
millénaires telles que la jeunesse
éternelle ah regarde là il y en a
regarde c'est la baie de gogi petit
fruit orangé de la famille des tomates
que Valérie cueille avec délicatesse on
choisi les bien mû bien colorés charnu
et bien orangé vert Millon voire rouge
je préfère cueillir avec la queue pour
qu'elle se conserve mieux comme ça au
frigo on peut les garder une dizaine de
jours sans problème et pour le contrôle
qualité l'agricultrice peut compter sur
son fils e mange pas tout gourmand mets
les dans de kangourou s'il te plaît ah
oui c'est super bon il a presque même
pas besoin de les croquer originaire de
Méditerranée la baie de goji est d'abord
exporté en Chine 90 % des B produites
dans le monde proviennent désormais du
marché asiatique pourtant il y a 5 ans
c'est bien dans l'ois que Valérie décide
d'en développer la culture un Paris sur
l'avenir alors la bê Googie elle pousse
très bien sur un sol calcaire et notre
plateau picar il est justement très
calcaire le climat évoluant on arrive à
des taux d'ensoleillement suffisants
maintenant pour produire la bê de goji
connu pour ses qualités gustatives la
baie de goji s'installe de plus en plus
dans le régime alimentaire des Français
et contrairement aux idées reçues elles
ne se consomment pas qu'en fruits secs
on a l'habitude de les trouver sèches
dans les magasins mais en fait c'est
comme tous les fruits c'est meilleur
frais il y a plus de vitamines et il y a
tous les bienfaits euh et le goût est
plus savoureux c'est le fruit qui
contient le plus de vitamine C au kilo
elle est aussi très riche en acid aminé
la France ne compte qu'une vingtaine de
producteurs de Bai de goji d'où sa
valeur pour des baies fraîches et bio il
faudra compter en moyenne entre 80 et
100 € le kilo le prix d'une alimentation
à la fois saine et locale
voilà et puis retour en Corse dans ce
journal afin de prolonger la saison
touristique le domaine maestrachi a mise
en place des visites de son vignoble
l'occasion pour le public de découvrir
la culture de la vigne en biodynamie je
vous propose d'écouter Camille Anaïs
raout propriétaire du domaine au micro
de Paul claré et de Mae Poupard pour
télépaiser sur place nous accueillons
les gens entre 10h et 10h30 dès que le
groupe est entier nous commençons la
visite en leur expliquant un petit peu
l'historique familiale en les faisant
rentrer dans notre dans notre petit
monde et en essayant de leur faire
partager au mieux notre passion et notre
vécu voilà si en métropole l'automne
s'installe en Martinique la saison des
croisières est lancée je vous le disais
dans les titres les touristes
nord-américains ont débarqué dans la
baie de fort- de- France avec plus de
240 arrivées programmées cette saison
s'annonce prometteuse embarquement avec
l crgis pour via TV sur
place la croisière est bien partie pour
s'amuser pour cette nouvelle saison ce
matin dans la baie de Fort de France le
premier bateau a fait escale à son bord
des visiteurs nord-américains ce couple
de Québécois est à la recherche de
l'authenticité
locale culture l'oire de l' et connaî
les personnes d'ici aussi la façon que
les gens
vivent important et ensuite on visite
les églises on visite les
restaurants les choses culturelles un
retour attendu par tous les
professionnels qui gravitent autour des
croisières c'est le cas des
excursionnistes pour eux c'est la
meilleure période en terme d'activité
c'est une période qui assez importante
pour nous parce que bon on fait un petit
peu plus plus plus important chiffre
d'affaire voilà avec plus de 240
arrivées programmées cette saison
s'annonce plutôt positive le nombre de
navires est en hausse plus 20 % par
rapport à l'année dernière c'est vrai
que c'est la 2è saison après covid
l'année dernière c'était la première
saison elle était déjà bonne celle-ci
sera encore meilleure puisqu'on attend
environ 240 escales sur la Martinique
avec un potentiel de 400000 passagers
sur l'ensemble du territoire cette année
encore les mouillages aont lieu au
marins enence d'Arly et Saint-Pierre la
ville d'arrêt d'histoire se prépare pour
ce défi avec 32 escales c'est vraiment
un enjeu de territoire la porte est en
Saint-Pierre et que les touristes
puissent se déplacer sur toutes les
villes autour également
maintenant c'est bien sûr aussi un enjeu
économique puisque on espère évidemment
que ces touristes consomment sur la
ville et sur le territoire après 2
années perdues pour cause de crise
sanitaire le secteur semble donc
redémarrer en fanfare cette saison dans
le sillage de 2022 devrait générer
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros à
l'économie
touristique et puis du côté de la SAR
maintenant les pompiers ont testé un
protocole de sauvetage des œuvres d'art
et objets du patrimoine au cœur de
l'abaye de l'Épau au man ces uvres
magnifiques demandent une intense
vigilance afin d'éviter que ne se
reproduise un dramatique événement comme
lors de l'incendie de Notre-Dame de
Paris on écoute le commandant Benoît
Guérin au micro d'Enzo mobert pour LMTV
Sart le but de cet exercice c'est de
tester le plan de sauvegarde des biens
culturels ce document vise à inventorier
toutes les œuvres qui sont présente au
sein de la bay royale de l'épa et de
définir des priorités d'évacuation
ou de sauvegarde sur site de ces
différentes urves on ouvre une page de
sport dans ce journal le weekend dernier
se déroulait la journée paralympique à
Paris alors comment les paraathlètes
voient les Jeux paralympiques de 2024
notre partenaire 20 minutes TV a posé la
question aux principaux concé
regardez toute la journée ils ont signé
des autographes et ils ont même pu éch
une partie de tennis de table avec le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron à 10 mois de leur j les athlètes
paralympiques ont définitivement gagné
leur lettre de noblesse là on sent que
ça change et grâce à Paris 2024 moi mon
handicap c'est déficience intellectuelle
et que c'est pas parce que on a
déficience intellectuelle que on peut
rien faire dans la vie on peut faire
plein de choses on peut faire du sport
donc c'est une bonne chose pour moi
Yassine est à mobilité réduite et a bien
reçu
aujourd'hui cet amateur se teste sur les
rampes avec son fauteuil je pense que
déjà des Jeux Olympiques même quand ils
sont pas en France ça motive alors chez
soi au pied de de nos monuments au pied
de nos habitations et cetera forcément
que ça va créer des vocations mais le
hand sport manque aujourd'hui de
structures adaptées selon Timothé adolp
médaill d'argent du 100 m au Jeux
Paralympique de Tokyo on a des messages
sur insta effectivement de de jeunes qui
me disent on adore ce que tu fais on
aimerait faire la même chose mais j'ai
pas de guide j'ai pas de club alors ben
on essaie d'aider mais c'est pas
toujours facile de le faire à distance
en plus de nos obligations qu'on a au
quotidien pour Paris 2024 un fond vient
d'ailleurs d'être créé pour aider les
clubs à former leur personnel à la queue
de joueurs handicapés comme Geffrey li
qui guide Timothé lors de ses courses on
a un petit peu professionnalisé le rôle
de guide et maintenant des athlètes de
haut niveau pensent à à à remplir ce
rôle là alors qu'avant c'était plus du
bénévola ou des athlètes qui sont sur la
fin de carrière les paraathlètes
Français sauront sûrement suscité cet
engouement espéré ils avaient créer
l'exploit de doubler leur nombre de
médailles entre les éditions des Jeux
paralympiques de Tokyo et de
Rio voilà et puis dans vos kiosques je
vous rappelle la sortie d'un numéro
spécial du magazine Le Point consacré à
Toulouse notamment aux difficultés de
logement Jean-Luc moudinc maire de la
ville rose a pris le temps de répondre
en détail aux questions de Valérie ffer
et de Stéphane TPO l'ebdomadaire s'est
aussi intéressé au pôles de
compétitivité Aérospace Vallé et aux
femmes inspirantes qui font Toulouse
aujourd'hui une édition spéciale à
retrouver chez vos marchands de journaux
et puis cette fin de journal parce que
Vincent van GOOG n'a pas seulement peint
à Arles et à Paris le château d'eau vert
suroise se glisse dans le sillage de
l'exposition événement du musée d'orsé
pour proposer un parcours original sur
les derniers voyages du maître
hollandais à l'occasion des 170 ans de
sa naissance une équipe de VO News a
visité l'exposition pour nous tous
regarder au château d'au ver sururroise
c'est une invitation au voyage au côté
de Vincent VOG que vous propose cette
toute nouvelle
exposition voyage à travers les derniers
lieux parcourus par l'artiste harles
Saint-Rémi de Provence mais aussi Paris
où Vincent a rejoint son frère on a
désiré ici reproduire la vue que Vincent
bog avait de cet appartement sur les
toit de Paris qu'il a reproduite
nombreuses nombreuses reprises également
un jeu de ces croquis qui sont
évidemment des reproductions ici mais
qui sont très belle reproduction au ver
suroise est le dernier voyage de Van Gog
l'artiste va y peindre 74 tableaux en 70
jours une ville qu'il découvre grâce à
son frère au moment où il décide de
devenir artiste il échange avec th son
fr qui va être son soutien financier et
affectif pendant toute cette période et
il dit Théo j'ai le mal du pays le mal
du pays des tableaux il veut retrouver
le pays des tableaux il a tenté à ce
momentlà pendant 4 ans de devenir
prédicateur et donc il avait quitté le
monde des tableaux puisqueavant il était
marchand d'art en tant que marchandard
il avait vu des tableaux tout le temps
dont de nombreux tableaux d'over surise
et donc retrouvver ce territoire là il
avait jamais mis les pieds physiquement
mais qu'il connaissait par cœur à
travers les œuvres pour lui c'était un
retour au pays des
tableaux
les toiles de Van GOOG présenté ne sont
évidemment pas des œuvres originales
mais des reproductions à l'échelle d'un
réalisme plus vrai que nature le Musée
Van Gog d'Amsterdam nous a offert une
série de neuf tableaux qui sont d'
réalisme vraiment bluffant et c'est vrai
que il faut un œil sacrément entraîné
pour voir la différence y compris dans
la pâte vraiment des œuvres sont en
relief les couleurs sont
parfaitement restitué et même les cadres
d'origine sont reproduits l'exposition
se termine dans cette grande salle de
300 m² avec une projection immersive et
mouvante à
360° sur le séjour de VOG à aut suroise
l'exposition VOG les derniers voyages
est à voir jusqu'au 29 septembre 2024 au
château d'
veruroise voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition du Grand git des territoires au
revoir à
tous
[Musique]